hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
third update on our Twitter $10,000
challenge the idea behind this is to try
to make $10,000 a new business using
only Twitter and I know a lot of
entrepreneurs are struggling to try to
make social media work for them and I
was in the same boat you know is this is
going to generate business is just a
waste of time and so the idea here is
I'm partnering up with one of the
experts Shawn Moffitt who helps business
owners generate business through Twitter
and using his methodology to try to get
new clients that come on board and I
update you guys every so often so far as
pin weekly we'll see how it goes my last
update was I had a contract for twenty
five hundred dollars with a new client
who didn't want to be mentioned in the
videos we have signed that agreement so
that's official and you saw me on air
follow up with Cisco who was wanted to
get together to talk about a potential
opportunity and I followed up with them
live through that video and we're
talking on Friday so I'm talking with
their digital marketing manager and
we'll see what kind of opportunities
come from that but no official signed
deal beyond the one that I talked before
just again to quickly show you my
process this is my homepage dashboard I
use this throughout my business and I
found that this really helps save me a
lot of time because all the tools I used
on a regular basis are here but the main
one that I use for this purpose is over
here we're basically every day I have a
list of companies that I want to follow
up with and so today's Wednesday so I
click on the W and it would pull in
their most recent tweets and then I
would look through them and try to
respond to the ones I thought were
interesting and the idea here is every
week to try to stay in touch with
somebody and just keep myself on the
radar and be a helpful resource or
connector for them and so just to show
you some of the responses that have come
in it's just a lot of dialogue right now
it's not a sales pitch that we're trying
to have here it's basically get on their
radar hopefully check out the profile
and if there's an opportunity they want
to contact me so here are some examples
so Cisco they would post something I
would just say keep it up there are back
they concur
Trant wiley posted something I wrote
scary you know indeed and they wrote
back get response these are mostly short
these guys are sharing their articles or
useful information they want to put out
there on their on their accounts and so
i'll respond on something something like
this if i just find it interesting or
might add my two cents and share an
opinion if i have something more to say
but for the most part they're pretty
short is just to get on the radar screen
and if you do this enough i know for me
when somebody comments on my channel
enough i want to know who this person is
if it's a one-off thing then maybe not
but on an ongoing basis then I usually
check out their profile and so that's
the hope here is by staying in touch
with them on a regular basis they're
going to check out my profile see what I
do and hopefully leads to an opportunity
like it did with the first company
another one from Microsoft SMB thanks
very much have a great weekend I just
wrote some good tips here on one of the
articles so finding helpful friendly
ways just to connect with people the
other thing that I've done is we've made
a list of the most engaged brands for
entrepreneurs so one of the ways that i
use to get on the radar screen of my
potential clients or prospects is i make
a list of all of the top brands who are
on facebook and i let them know how
they're doing because i can help them do
better and so then they see how they're
going up against a competition they
often want to get involved so we made a
list email I'm i tweeted the companies
so here's one so this was visa and they
wrote back and I'll back which is the
happy face and whatever we'll see that
we keep communicating maybe something
will develop and then the other one that
I do so the third initiative is I do a
daily oh so this is the most engage
brains again Francisco I do a daily
champion of small business so the
companies that I target are all you know
interested in helping entrepreneurs and
they have twitter account to share
information to help entrepreneurs and so
every day I recognize a new one of them
on my account and idea here and this
came from sean is just show some
appreciation to them you know so you're
not just you're not just saying great
article or retweeted one of the things
it's finding a way to thank them
publicly so that your list knows about
it and you know they get recognized and
so they're likely going to reach out as
well so we do a daily champion of small
business and I you know I reply to the
person who are the companies I want to
get in touch with and often though right
back something as simple as thanks Evan
this may not ever lead to anything you
know there may not have an opportunity
that comes up but the idea again is if
you have a big enough list of people
that you're doing it with and I think
mine is 70 or 80 at the moment now and
you reach out to them once a week and
you just stay on top of their radar
screen eventually if they have an
opportunity they're going to want to
come to you as at least a first option
to see if there's an opportunity to work
together so lets you pick up date for
this week and hopefully I'll have more
to report on the next update so thank
you guys if you like this video series
and you want to see more about how I'm
generating money just through Twitter
please give it a thumbs up below I
always love seeing those come in and I'd
love to hear your feedback if you won't
leave a comment under this video or if
you have a question be happy to try to
answer it for you so thank you and I'll
see you on the next episode